رصدت الجزيره حجم الدمار الواسع الذي
خلفته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بعد
انسحابها من اجزاء واسعه من حي الصفطاوي
شمالي مدينه غزه ونقلت شهادات ناجين من
اهالي
الحي يعني هذه هي منطقه الصفطاوي شمال
مدينه غزه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
انسحبت من اجزاء واسعه من هذه المنطقه
محدثه دمارا وحرائق سعه فيها حيث استهدفت
الابراج السكنيه بحرائق بحرائق كما
تشاهدونها في الخلفيه وايضا لم تبقي سياره
واحده الا واحدثت بها حرائق او هرستها
الدبابات الاسرائيليه في هذا الحي دمار
واسع في هذه المنطقه اول شيء احنا طلعنا
من السويدي هنا اجونا الجيش و طلعونا من
السويدي اعتقلوا من الشباب في منهم سابوهم
ومهم خلوهم والنساء حطوهم في حليمه
السعديه بعدين تفرقوا الدمار اللي في
السويدي هنا لا يوصل صف لا يرثى اليه من
ناحيه دمار من حرق من سرقت حتى اغراض
النازحين من ايدين الاسرائيليين تم سرقهم
من ادوات منزليه من لابتوبات من جوالات من
الى اخره وهنا ايضا مصنع من اكبر المصانع
في قطاع غزه لادوات التنظيف وهو مصنع حبوش
ايضا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي دمرته بشكل
كامل واحرقت جميع المعدات وال والمواد
الخام بداخله هذه حديقه حيوان نماء لم
يبقى بها حيوانا حدا على قيد الحياه كانت
تؤوي مئات الحيوانات وكانت مقصدا للناس من
كافه انحاء قطاع غزه يعني هذه عياده
الانرو التي كانت تؤوي الاف النازحين فيها
واخرجت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالقوه
واعتقلت عددا من الشبات شبان واعدمت بعضهم
كما تشاهدون قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ايضا احرقتها ولم تسلم هذه المؤسسه
الدوليه من النيران
الاسرائيليه هنا يحاول الاهالي اخراج ما
تبقى
ع وهي العياده الوحي التي كانت ت نازحين
في هذه المقه شامل على كل الناس كل غزه
ادمر طبش احنا بدنا ن انا زيك زي ما انت
شايف حرقين الدنيا حق الشارع بخشو وحرقو
حر كل الدور حرق وكل المحلات حرق
والسيارات ما خلوا ولا حاجه حسبنا الله
ونعم
الوكيل